>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Pam Jackson: Good afternoon.
[ Laughter ]
Mic works.
I'm Pam Jackson.
I'm Director for the Center for
the Book here at the Library
of Congress, and we're
part of the new national
and international outreach unit.
And we welcome you to
this afternoon's program.
A part of our vision here at
the Library of Congress is
that we are the chief steward of the
record of knowledge of America and,
thus, the world, creating a
springboard to the future.
And it's a future that I just create
in my mind that's one of compassion
and courage and industry and
achievement and accomplishment
and honor and peace and harmony.
And I believe there's nothing more
wonderful than the art of poetry
to be both a healing, soothing balm
and a vibrant source
of self-expression.
Sometimes it's an equalizer.
Sometimes it's a neutralizer.
A part of the Library's
central mission is
to provide the American people
with a very rich, enduring source
of knowledge that can be
relied upon to inform,
engage, and inspire societies.
And today's program's a
part of that endeavor.
Here at the Center for the
Book, which includes the Poetry
and Literature Center and the Young
Readers Center, we promote books
and library, literacy and
reading, poetry and literature,
knowing that they're best tools
for engaged, informed societies,
for the protection and
preservation of democracy,
and they're the best weapons
against ignorance and intolerance.
Today, we have the opportunity
to explore ways in which poetry
and poetry publishing push us to
understand our national dialogue
on race and to do so
in empowering ways.
And to start us off on our
discussion, we have Rob Casper,
who's the Head of the
Library of Congress Poetry
and Literature Center, who will
introduce our four poet publishers.
I'd like to bring Rob to the
microphone and just acknowledge him
for being a very remarkable
and inspiring,
bright and talented human being
who's a very big contributor
to the Library and
the poetry community.
Welcome, Rob.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Thank you, Pam.
I'm excited to introduce
today's panel,
which I have a personal
connection to.
Not so long ago before starting
this job as the Head of the Poetry
and Literature Center, I published
the literary magazine jubilat,
and Cathy Park Hong and Evie
Shockley were the last two editors I
had the privilege of working with.
In a sense, this panel
represents both a continuation
and an expansion of
our conversations.
I also owe a debt to my program
specialist, Anya Creightney,
who helped develop the
panel from the beginning.
Thank you, Anya.
Before I begin, let me ask you
to turn off your cell phones
and any electronic devices you have
that might interfere with our event.
Second, please note that this
program is being recorded,
and by participating,
you give us permission
for any future use of the recording.
Finally, let me tell you a little
bit about the Poetry and Literature.
We are home to the Poet
Laureate Consultant on Poetry,
and we put on 30 to 40 public
programs like this one per year.
In two days' time, for instance,
we're featuring poet Monica Youn
in our first ever Law
and Literature Program.
To find out more about the Season of
Literature Programs at the Library,
you can go check out the table
in the back in the foyer,
or you can visit our
website, www.loc.gov/poetry.
Here's how today's event will work.
First, I've asked each panelist
to come up to the podium
and read a poem they've published,
which they feel speaks to issues
about race in ways that
prose or other forms
of artistic expression cannot.
Afterwards, I will lead a moderated
discussion, and we'll have plenty
of time at the end of the
program for your questions.
We also have books for sale by all
of our poet panelists,
poet/editor panelists.
And I know they'll be happy to
have -- to sign them for you.
You can read more about
our panelists
in the program you should all have,
if not on your chair,
next to your chair.
But let me say how proud I
am to have them all here,
traveling from around the country.
Each of them are dynamic, open,
insightful, and deeply engaged,
both as poets and editors,
and together,
I know we'll explore how
poems enrich and challenge,
as well as the Royal Literal
Magazines and Presses play
in getting poetry to
its eager readers.
Please join me in welcoming Carmen
Giménez Smith, Cathy Park Hong,
Don Share, and Evie Shockley.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith: I go first?
And I just read the poem, and then
I talk about how I feel about it?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Hi. I'm so glad to be here.
I'm going to read a poem by
Vanessa Villarreal, who is a poet.
I'm a publisher.
I have a small press
called Noemi Press.
It's a press that's celebrating
its 15th year next year.
It started as a Chapbook Press,
and we've been publishing
full-length collections
for about eight years now.
This book is from a series that
we published called "Acrylica".
The Acrylica Series is named
after our Poet Laureate Juan
Felipe Herreras [sic - Herrera],
groundbreaking multi
-- bilingual collection
of poetry called "Acrylica".
And the series, which
has published four books
and has really exciting books coming
out, is interested in the work
of innovative Latino writers.
This book, "Beast Meridian"
by Vanessa Villarreal,
will be published in
March of next year.
"Girl Body Gift".
First dress as a boy, an earlied 11.
Iron Papi's khakis, a Dickies
crease with white T-shirt,
gel comb black, slick
back como linda.
Me and my girls look
hard, get caught.
Papi's hands crush my neck.
No te compones tue matadas
aqui no quiero jotas.
First kiss, 12, Chancey,
Saturn 9, Centaur,
trembling to Jodesi
[assumed spelling].
First boyfriend Tyrone, MJ smile.
You want to go with me.
Spiral perm and boys to men to
sleep in his Rockets jersey.
Papi's backhand.
No quiero queandes
colos pinches negros.
First against light-eyed Cedric,
dream prince of pines
appears at a sleepover.
The moon is a pill in my can.
Dazed, I kneel, dick a dark poppy.
No, a muffled petal in my throat.
Not all my yet tells his boys.
First white boy, summer night,
a stolen sapphire justing
[assumed spelling].
Shooting stars on slide.
Three AM, taut orchid drum.
Mami pregnant due to work at
seven, searching the milky fog,
caught in Chevy headlights.
Slut to his boys, bifurcate
my head, shave bottom half.
Rocks pelt my back on
tracks, and with my new names,
I can now fathom my father.
Hospital roommate Nicole, lily-firm
breasts on sterile white sheets.
Hillary, pink vodka mattress.
Tina and Li, a yearning
of triangles.
Seventeen, Dr. Wright's, hymen
intact, a knot hot and sharp
as wood salt on the
cord in my star heart.
I'm interested in this
poem for many reasons.
I love the compression
in the language,
but I also really appreciate
how it inscribes a couple
of different things.
One of them is the racial issues
that emerge among people of color,
which I think is a question
or a problem or an issue
that not too many people
engage with,
but I think is really important as a
person of color to consider the ways
in which we all participate in
the horizontal oppression of race.
I also think that one
of the challenges
of being a Latina is the ways
in which our sexuality is used
as a kind of currency
and Latina sexuality
and I guess affect is
stereotyped or made precious.
And I appreciate that this poem
does a really beautiful job
of complicating what
Latina sexuality is.
So thank you.
>> Cathy Park Hong: Hi.
Hi. I'm the -- I'm the Poetry
Editor for the New Republic,
which used to be solely based in DC,
and now it also has an
office in New York City.
And I'm relatively new.
I became editor I think in
2014, in the winter of 2014.
And it was actually a
very contentious time
for that magazine because, you know,
there was a whole walkout,
a whole staff walkout.
And this was all over the news,
and there was a big uproar,
and a lot of journalists were
saying, the New York Times
and so forth, that the
magazine was destroyed.
And then the editor in chief,
Gabriel Snyder, at the Times,
who is actually a friend of
mine, called me up and asked me
if I wanted to be the poetry
editor, which was shock --
which was very much a surprise
to me because it's a perch
that I haven't been
in for a long time --
on for a long time except I used
to edit jubilat with Rob and Evie.
So it was definitely -- I
was ambivalent about it,
but then I grew to love it.
And, you know, one, I thought
I would read the inaugural poem
that I actually commissioned from a
young poet named Rickey Laurentiis.
And, you know, though there was
this huge uproar about the mag --
how the magazine was
destroyed, there were, you know,
a few people who were
saying, you know,
maybe the magazine
needs some revamping,
including Ta-Nehisi Coates,
who in The Atlantic said
that -- what was he saying?
Let's see.
How the family rose at
TNR's virtual funeral looks
like a whites-only section of
a Jim Crow era movie house.
For most of the modern history,
TNR has been an entirely
white publication.
So I thought as my part as the
poetry editor, it would be --
I wanted to kind of
revise that legacy.
And this is a poem by -- called
"Continuance" by Rickey Laurentiis.
And it was a few months
past Ferguson.
So it's actually in memoriam to
-- for Ferguson and Mike Brown.
Ferguson, Missouri,
2014, In Memoriam.
Forever here, Mister Dark, and
tricking me, Steaming from a manhole
in Missouri Or else you're damp
between the motions of the trees,
Revealing the breezy discourse
of those trees, black Sound.
I can see now how everything
I've learned of you is wrong.
How an air Of dumb assumption
lounged on my brow, A liar, winking,
claiming a shadow is as
empty As my childhood vision
of the falling sun meant emptiness.
But every child knows what
moves the wind at night,
Knows what leads some birds
to develop their unrest
In the high green of
some trees or, lower,
What leans against that
tree's bark: a man?
Or is it The
just-barely-intelligible idea
of one?
Head back, Maybe eyes
closed, moaning,
working to hysteria
The erection rising
like a haunted chain away from him.
If I move closer, carrying
a glass cup?
If my mouth Is that cup?
Though I've known fear move
as bravely In this world,
move like a physical man, it
can shoot a boy -- So shoot me.
Who said that?
Was it really The black
of my tongue?
But how could any breed Of blackness
ever wish to be penetrated?
I could tell you How a foot creaks
even falling dead In the night,
could tell the red a mother cries
Once she feels that absence drop,
like pity, inside her, But I
cannot say what a bullet says
as it enters a child's skin.
But come in.
You can enter me, Mister Dark.
Let Tonight be the first night
I deeper see the pregnant
Possibilities of your design.
How your fingers move To build
such attitudes, turning a moaning
of the wind Into a man, making what
is a tease of grass at the heel
Into terror, now pleasure,
then back to grass again.
Aren't you the mirror in
which all lights balance?
Aren't you the line on
which all lines cross?
Anything lives in you, so that that
dark over there Can be the dark
of Mike Brown, full of breath; that
the dark Right here can be the dark
of my own bastard mind,
That this dark come closest
to my lips Is a shadow's
knowledge, full, not ever empty,
Charitable as is wicked, risky as
is good, fascination, Perversion,
and I move to it, to
you, a shadow-chaser,
Hearing the birds make
restlessness in the trees,
Watching the man stroke velvet
from his body, Head still back,
maybe eyes parted, singing now --
He's at that point when I must
surrender My knees to gravity,
and, mouth ready, get gone.
I'll choose what ground I lie on.
>> Don Share: I'll read a poem
from the March 2014
issue of Poetry Magazine.
Since this poem appeared, it's
gotten about 12,000 hits a day
on the PoetryFoundation.org website.
Also in this issue were poems
from Claudia Rankine's Citizen,
although the book hadn't
come out yet.
And the best thing to do is to look
for the poet reading
this poem on YouTube.
It's Danez Smith, "alternate
names for black boys".
1. smoke above the burning bush 2.
archnemesis of summer night 3.
first son of soil 4.
coal awaiting spark & wind 5.
guilty until proven dead 6.
oil heavy starlight 7.
monster until proven ghost 8.
gone 9. phoenix who
forgets to un-ash 10.
going, going, gone 11.
gods of shovels & black veils 12.
what once passed for kindling 13.
fireworks at dawn 14.
brilliant, shadow hued coral 15.
(I thought to leave this blank
but who am I to name us nothing?)
16. prayer who learned
to bite & sprint 17.
a mother's joy & clutched breath.
This issue of Poetry Magazine
was produced in collaboration
with the Split this
Rock Poetry Festival.
It was co-edited with Sarah
Browning, who's in the room.
And both Sarah Browning and Split
this Rock are institutions y'all can
support locally and should.
And when we published these
poems, this was before Ferguson,
before so much that we're used
to waking up to and hearing
in the news relentlessly
was starting to become known
to the general and wider world.
And sometimes poems and poets
become fixed in the time
and place of our imaginations.
And Danez is one.
Claudia Rankine is another.
The issue also had Tim
Seibles and Nikky Finney.
When we put that issue together,
we read, as we always do
at the magazine and with our
co-editor, in this case Sarah.
We look for the best poems.
We were looking for poems
that meant something to us
as people, as readers, you know?
Sometimes a word, we'll talk about
this gatekeeper gets tossed around.
But we weren't -- we had no gates
and weren't keeping anything.
We were putting poems in front
of eyeballs, and we believed
in the poets and the poems,
and we knew their significance
and vitality.
But what we didn't understand
yet was how these poems,
like the best poems, sort of know
things before everyone else does.
Poems know what's going to happen
before things happen in a way
because poets are people.
I'm stealing from Henry James,
but they're people on
whom nothing is lost.
And so, sadly, these poems came
to a kind of moment sometime
after the publication
in these pages occurred.
And although I'm sorry that the
occasion for the poetry recurs,
I'm glad that the poets were
there, not just for readers now
with whom they resonate, but I think
when people look back on our time
and want to know what
was going on here,
they'll have the history books.
And they'll say certain things.
And there'll be sort of
journalism available to people.
But if they want to know what it
was like, they'll turn to the poets.
If they want to know
what were these --
what were people doing when
all this stuff happened,
they'll turn to the
poets and the poems.
And so, there are many other
poems I think all of us could read
that have come to occupy a place
that I think will never be --
just, you know, that these poems
will never become dislodged,
though you never know.
But I think that's something we had
gotten complacent about as editors,
as readers, that we thought poems
and poetry was a kind of process
that was always unfolding
and always kind of there.
What we didn't I think realize
and we do now is the urgency
and necessity for this
work to help us under --
not only understand what's
going on, but to fight things
that need fighting
and to empower people
who didn't have the power to fight.
>> Evie Shockley: Hi.
I'm Evie Shockley, and I currently
am the Creative Writing Editor
for Feminist Studies, which is
primarily an academic journal
in the field of women's and
genders' sexuality studies,
but from its inception, Feminist
Studies has always published
creative writing.
And I was very delighted when I
was asked to come on, come on board
and serve on the editorial
board in that --
the role of particular sort of
shepherd of creative writing.
My work there, though,
involves a much smaller volume
because there are only, you know,
a certain number of pages per issue
in a journal that only publishes
a couple to three times a year.
A small volume of creative
work, and because I work
with creative nonfiction,
fiction, and poetry,
an even smaller volume of poetry.
So I'm going to be reading
and talking about a poem
that I published when I was working
on jubilat with Rob and Cathy.
And so, this poem is one that we
published in jubilat 18 in 2010.
It's by a poet named Marcus Wicker,
and the title is "Love
Letter to Justin Timberlake".
When I think of you it is
always of a small, locked room.
A principal's dark, full lips
pressed together in a smirk.
A glare from his fat, gold
herringbone chain burning tears
in my eyes, my face red as
yours in direct sunlight.
And even as my voice shut
down that day, I knew ditching
to buy NSYNC's CD was worth more
than Prescriptive Speech class.
What I heard -- four voices
harmonized in a plastic bottle.
Your falsetto, blowing the top off.
Michael Jackson with no abusive
boxer father or snatched childhood.
Sam Cooke sans German shepherds
stalking through his songs.
I've been watching James Brown
and Jackie Wilson make
pelvic fixation public domain
since I was old enough
to work a remote.
And I have yet to elude
starched lines.
How did you learn to dance
your way out of boxes?
Or did you find it
easy as breathing,
like whistling the national anthem?
Do you remember the Super Bowl?
How you tore Janet
Jackson's breast from her top?
I love you that way.
Her earth-brown bounty of flesh --
large, black nipple pierced,
wind chapped, hardened.
And you saying, Go ahead.
Look.
I chose this poem out of
the many I could have gone
with because it takes up a
subject that has been back
in the news somewhat spectacularly
in the last few weeks,
cultural appropriation.
I'm thinking of the novelist Lionel
Shriver's highly publicized remarks
in defense of what she described
as a writer's right to imagination,
to create characters whose identity
is different in some respects
or in many from the writer's own.
In the wake of her talk, which she
delivered wearing a sombrero just
to be clear, there has been
a widespread conversation
about the difference between the
necessary and often vital work
of a writer depicting lives
outside of their own experience
and the problematic
all too common instance
of a societally privileged
writer exploiting the cultures
and identities of disenfranchised,
socially marginalized others.
Wicker's poem locates the issue
in the realm of music rather
than literature, of course, but
it gives us a space for thinking
about the same questions raised by
Shriver's expression of entitlement
to instrumentalize and commodify
the experience of the less powerful.
The form of the poem allows
Wicker to initiate our thinking
about these things without
ever using the phrase
cultural appropriation.
It begins with a scene of memory
in which the speaker is in trouble
for not being where he was
supposed to be, in class,
and as a result has been
re-confined in a small, locked room.
His adoration of NSYNC, the boy band
in which Timberlake got his start,
has made the punishment
worth it to the speaker.
The poem sets the speaker's love
and trouble in the context of a list
of African American musician
performers whom both he
and Timberlake apparently love,
Michael Jackson and Sam Cooke,
James Brown and Jackie Wilson.
A deep --
A deep appreciation for
the genius of these men
as entertainers is what the speaker
and Timberlake have in common.
But while the speaker also shares
with them an experience of trouble,
his tears and shut-down voice
shadows Michael Jackson's experience
of abuse and Cooke's of being
stalked by German shepherds,
Timberlake's done taken
their blues and gone.
How did you learn to dance
your way out of boxes?
The speaker apostrophizes
his one-time hero.
The subsequent lines of the poem
suggest that the answer has much
to do with Timberlake's
easy sense of belonging
in a white supremacist nation.
Wicker ends with a fascinating
and disquieting image
of Timberlake enacting his
access or right to black culture,
which is embodied in not Michael,
but Janet Jackson's
earth-brown bounty of flesh.
This Jackson, who also
bears the marks of trouble,
her exposed breast is pierced,
wind-chapped, hardened, lays bare,
so to speak, the currency Timberlake
has traded in for his success.
And in a move that
Shriver could learn from,
Wicker problematizes his
own participation in this
between men triangle that in turn
instrumentalizes black women's
bodies with the productively
ambiguous admission,
"I love you that way."
Bought and paid for.
>> Rob Casper: Wow.
What a great group of
presentations [inaudible] to be
in this conversation with.
So very -- and as the presentations
were very [inaudible] all asserting
the essential power of
[unintelligible] poem.
I want to begin by sort of
riffing off of what Don said
about this particular moment
and ask you all to weigh
in on how you feel that's happening
in poetry right now
[inaudible] the poems
that you've been [inaudible]
publish, especially poems
that relate to issues of race.
It's part of a larger tradition.
I mean there's something to be said
about how these poems may be sort
of working within our culture,
but there's also something
to be said about, you know,
the lineage they come from
and the lineage that we
are championing as editors.
So maybe you could talk about that?
>> Cathy Park Hong: I'll begin I
mean I think that I am a poet and --
who's always been interested in
race because of who I am and just,
you know, and because
of my politics.
And it's something that I, you
know, have always confronted.
And that was something I wanted
to bring in as an editor.
And even though when I first
turned down that editing job,
I was a little bit nervous and
skeptical about the position.
I realize that it was a great
opportunity to publish poets
who wouldn't normally be
published in a glossy magazine.
And so, that was --
and it's been really --
I mean basically I've
been able to --
poets who I tend to love are
poets [inaudible] pull in politics
into their setting,
into their language.
And it's not just that
they're writing about race
or they're writing about this.
And I think one -- this is something
that I get a little bit worried
about now because right now
there's been this national discourse
on race.
It's a real hot button
issue right now.
It's been like that
for the last few years.
But this is also the
history of America.
But I think our tendencies, our
historical literary tendency is kind
of sort of decide when to turn
the camera on race and when
to turn it away from race.
And what I'm afraid is that,
you know, I think our interest
in race right now especially
as poets or [inaudible]
between the poem about race as an
occasional poem, you know, only.
Oh, now since we're talking about
Islamophobia, why don't we bring
up this poem by this non-Muslim
poet and pay attention to her?
And then, you know, so it becomes --
so the identity of the poet of color
is usually so much more attached
to what's going on politically.
And, you know, for me as a poet
and as an editor it's really more
about that [inaudible] this
conversation is sustained
and continued.
And I do think that actually our
literary landscape is changing,
you know?
I do think that, you know, even
though I have that concern,
that worry, I also think
that we're having a bit
of a renaissance right now in terms
of the amazing number of poets
of color who have been
getting published [inaudible].
Yeah.
>> Rob Casper: Anybody else
want to jump in on that?
Really it's a question about what
may have preceded this moment,
both in terms of what publishers
have done, but also in terms
of what poets were doing, writing
about issues related to race.
That may be changing now in
terms of, as you said, Cathy,
how it fits into what this sort
of larger national conversation.
But still, I mean my
feeling as an editor is
that there were poems
there, you know.
There have been poems throughout
our history that have been there
that at times, as you said, Cathy,
the cultural lens has turned
to maybe for different
reasons or in different ways.
But I definitely felt like
in the editing that we did,
we were more of a larger
and older tradition.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Don Share: Well, I don't
think I can improve upon anything
that either of you have
said, but I point out,
and I think I can point it out
because I'm older than you guys.
I'm looking around.
I remember, you know, when I was
coming up what poetry was like.
And it's not like it is now.
It will never be that again,
which I think is fantastic.
But the point that we're
all sort of getting at is
that institutions have
been transformed.
I mean Cathy touched on this
talking about the New Republic,
which has been around
for a substantial portion
of American history.
It's been around since
the 19th century.
The nation has been
around that long.
Poetry's been around for over
a hundred years, and so on.
And so what you're seeing is that
poetry and literature as it sort
of lived in places such
as literary magazines
or magazines was not
reflecting reality
for a very long period of time.
All that's happening now
is that it's doing that.
And in the process of reflecting
what we all know, whatever we think
and feel about issues of the day
to be reality, those magazines
in our culture have
become transformed.
And so, I don't think
it will ever go back
to something that it was before.
And what it was before
is not -- we're not --
I don't think any of us would
sort of put down, you know,
a kind of poem or poetry.
I mean, you know, history has
moments that arise out of necessity.
And we're in one of
those moments now.
In a sense, we always were.
But again, the magazines
didn't reflect it.
The literary history
wasn't open to it.
Our culture wasn't aware of it.
All that's happening now is because
people are aware of the poems
and poets we're talking
about, it means something
that poetry hadn't
meant for a long time.
So I think it's very
healthy and promising
that these transformations
are happening.
And I don't think that
can be undone.
I mean who knows, you know?
I just don't believe it.
I just don't believe what is
happening now will be undone.
I mean I think the strength of
poetry has found itself thanks
to new writer -- not new writers,
but writers who didn't
have the audiences
that other writers had before.
There's been tectonic shifts,
and I don't think you put
those plates back flat.
>> Cathy Park Hong: Can I just maybe
add something, just add to that
about -- and I think part of
that is also just technology
and the way that's changed.
As you mentioned, Don, you
[inaudible], and he's like,
you know, he's -- his
poetry's gone viral.
>> Don Share: Yeah.
>> Cathy Park Hong: You
know, which is great.
I mean there are a lot of
problems I have with technology,
but it's also very able to
democratize any process in that,
you know, people can
access poems so much easier.
And I think that's also made
it much more [inaudible].
>> Rob Casper: And I also just want
to briefly talk about institutions.
We have a sort of range of
institutions and a range
of publishers represented here,
both publishing, you know --
New Republic Magazine, but also
Carmen started Noemi Press.
Maybe you could talk about what
you're sort of entering into,
this sort of dialogue as
a publisher of your --
of your own press meant for you?
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith:
I started Noemi Press
with the intention always of
publishing writers of color
and endorsing the work of writers of
color, but also recognizing that --
and, you know, I started
it in 2002, which was --
it's like a different -- it's
like a different world
that I'm talking about.
And I think culturally coming
from a Latino background,
a South American -- my parents
are both from South America --
that the role of the poet and the
political body aren't separate,
that those two things are always
sort of part of the canonical -
of the canonical work of
Latin American poets on the --
how politics are always shaping
poetics and/or aesthetics,
and that conversation is ongoing.
And my awareness of that was
a big part of my approach.
But I think when I started Noemi
Press, I also recognized the history
of publishing and especially the
publishing of the work of people
of color and realized that
I had a battle to fight
against being marginalized
as a press who only --
who only published people of
color, as if that's problematic
or that ghettoizes the press.
And so, it's been really interesting
going through the process
of building a press and publishing
lots of different kinds of books
and slowing building
I guess a brand,
while watching also the evolution
of what I think the groundwork
that was laid in the '80s
and the early '90s of -
I remember my teachers -- the first
time that I read, for example,
Glorion's [assumed spelling]
"I'll Deal" [assumed spelling],
which I think for many women
of color, many people of couple
such a -- such an enormously
important moment of recognizing
that my sort of complex identity
is completely normal and relevant.
So watching subjectivity,
that kind of neutral,
uncontested subjectivity
get contested, the poetics,
the maybe particularly lyric
subjectivity being contested
as being this kind of
neutral space in which I'm --
you know, I can have these
kinds of experiences that tend
to be inscripted white because of
-- because of the canon, only not --
there's nothing specifically.
It just happens to be that this
enormous body of work that comes
to represent American poetry just
happened to be when I was coming
up as a young poet very white.
And so -- and so, first of all,
seeing how those early in those --
in the '90s and the early '00s
seeing that groundwork turning
into legitimate outrage, which I
didn't -- I hoped would happen.
I never imagined it would
happen at this scale.
And then just also adapting to
the shifting model of publishing,
and there -- and I think
that digital printing
also has a big part.
I think the technology and the shift
to digital printing made starting
a small press much easier.
And I think that equalized
the playing field in a way.
You didn't need $5,000 to
print a book of poetry.
You needed $500, $1,000 to print
out a couple -- and people --
and that gave -- that democratized
I think the industry in a way
that ended up helping
people of color a lot.
So I think what we're seeing now are
just the gains that are built off
of many generations of writers
of color contesting and --
contesting the terms of subjectivity
and slowly gaining ground.
And I think the nomination of Barack
Obama was kind of a tipping point
for all of us because it forced
all of us to confront racism,
some of us in not so wonderful ways.
But I think that it made --
it made us have to deal
with this untouched subject.
And there's no -- I'm going to
echo what everyone's saying.
There's no turning back.
And so, I feel like the work
that Noemi is publishing is more
and more engaged critically with
that conversation and also engaged
with the conversation of -- I
know that there's a conversation
about gatekeepers that's
really important.
But I think the other
more nuanced part
of the conversation is the
people who are building
and generating aesthetic ideals,
that that conversation is also
changing, that there's a wider range
of participation by different
kinds of people forming aesthetics,
creating, generating ideas
of what poetry is and can be.
And as a publisher, of course
I'm thrilled about that.
And I -- and I -- and I hope
that we are doing a good job
of representing that work.
But I'm just -- I feel like
the millennial generation
of poets are terrifyingly exciting
and are visionary and are the ones
who are going to change the world.
And I guess I feel like the years
that I put in building Noemi Press,
I'm glad that I did that so
that I can provide a forum
for these very exciting
young writers.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
I want to just push a little further
on this idea of how poetry fits
into the larger culture, what
it does especially when it comes
to talking about issues when
we're talking about race
that other forms [inaudible].
I thought it was really
interesting, Evie, when you talking
about problematizing participation.
And I was struck -- I
was struck too with --
in many of the poems that you read
that all of you the sort of violence
and beauty and how
they were intertwined
in a way that [inaudible].
I felt you brought the
notion of argument.
I mean we're awash
right now as a county
in these very divisive arguments.
And poetry I think has a way
of both clarifying an argument
and complicating an
argument at the same time.
I was hoping maybe you could talk
about what function poetry serves,
especially in talking about
issues related to race
that can be so fraught and divisive.
>> Evie Shockley: Well --
[ Laughter ]
[Inaudible] very important.
I want to hear it.
You know, I appreciate that
question because one of the things
that I think that we do when we make
spaces for all of the various kinds
of voices who are indeed
writing is we sort
of feed into a larger network.
You know, I'm wearing several
hats at this point, a poet,
publisher of poets,
teacher of poets.
And when I'm teaching
a class and I have --
even if it's not a poetry of color,
a black poetry class, for example,
I'm just teaching creative
writing classes.
And I have a wide range
of books that I can go to,
genres that I can use,
just pull off.
And they don't teach my
students something false
about the way American poetry
is being created right now
and in the past.
Then that makes my job as
teacher that much easier.
The kinds of classroom
conversations we can have expands,
and it helps me normalize
for them the --
this way things are now, right?
And it help -- it enables me to
help bring a generation of people
into writing for whom all
these traditions that make
up American poetry and beyond
are like already theirs
and that they will sort of
be the body of those lessons,
those aesthetics, those
conversations
as they begin their
careers as creators.
>> Cathy Park Hong: I thought Evie
[inaudible] cultural appropriation.
You know, I think it's -- I
agree with everyone, but it's --
you know, it's -- you know,
it's [inaudible] culture
of peoples happening right
now, a lot really great.
But then there's also some
[inaudible] things too,
as we're seeing in the
national political stage.
We're seeing echoes of that also in
the literary stage as well where,
you know, there are, you know, more
voices from different racial groups
and sexualities, gender,
politics, and so forth,
but that there are also people
like Lionel Shriver, who --
you know, I think there's now
grievances on both sides, right?
And there are also white writers
who also feel these grievances
[inaudible] cultural appropriation
seems to be keep -- seems
to keep popping up now.
I can also cite the
example of [inaudible].
I don't even remember what his
name was, a guy who pretended
to be a Chinese [inaudible] poetry.
And he seemed to think that
he was now underrepresented,
or he felt like he was -- you know,
his identity as a white
man was actually not --
was preventing him from being
published with his work.
So, you know, so there's identity
politics happening from the white --
you know, not [inaudible] too.
And one thing I want to say about
cultural appropriation is that like,
you know, is that if it -- and I
think people have already said this,
is that you can write about
anything you want, you know?
But you also -- it's not
-- it's not like freedom --
not a question of freedom
of speech or something.
But if someone's criticizing
you, you know,
you're still saying what you want.
You also have to be open
to criticism as well.
That's all -- you're
getting criticized, you know?
People are getting attack -- you
know, people are going to talk back,
whereas before there wasn't
that talking back, you know?
And I think a lot of that has
to do with, again, social media
and the Internet, where now,
you know, Twitter is great.
You know, people can talk back.
People of color can talk
back [inaudible] do that.
But that's not suppressing
your rights.
You know? One thing that I
will say is that, you know,
it's not just when -- I think it's
important for writers to write
about their cultures actually.
But I think like with
anything else, it takes --
it's not like can I do it?
It's how you do it.
You know, it's about -- it's
about like having empathy
and doing the research and having
the patience and really kind
of really trying to understand.
And that's something that Lionel
Shriver did not seem to get.
And a lot of these
writers don't seem
to get [inaudible] again
and again and again.
So.
>> Rob Casper: I'm thinking we
should take that issue a bit closer
to home and talk about the role
that white editors and editors
of color face when trying
to develop [inaudible].
We're addressing race.
I mean I -- we're [inaudible]
my experience with other editors
in my days at jubilat and
our failure effectively
to publish writers and poets.
In fact, the biggest
change for us, I think,
was not only having Evie and Cathy
as editors but Evie being able
to access the list of [inaudible].
But I think there's larger sort
of or deeper issues that writers
of color and what editors of color
and white editors face in trying
to do the best possible job
of representing the widest
possible community of poets.
I think you can talk about that.
>> Evie Shockley: I'll say
quickly that I mean one
of the things I think is implied
in your question but that I'd
like to sort of say out
loud is that we're talking
about publishing poems about race.
Part of what is just as important
as publishing poets of color,
whether they're talking
about race or not, right?
>> Cathy Park Hong: Yes.
>> Rob Casper: Yes.
>> Evie Shockley: And it's -- I
think in some ways it's that moment
that you're able to create enough
of a space in a particular journal
or publishing a, you know, poetry
series or whatever it might be.
You create enough of a space
where poets don't feel either
like they're -- maybe a politicized
aesthetic around race is unwelcome,
nor that that's the only way that
they can, you know, get in, is by,
you know, sort of proclaiming
something that's identity-based
or critique or protest-based.
That's part of the work that, you
know, that we were trying to do
and that I know that everyone
up here is trying to do.
And that's what -- that's
what makes the sea change,
is that you got people
feeling called
by what they are in
the sea [inaudible].
So the hard part is getting
over that initial tipping point.
And that is where you have
to go door to door I think.
>> Rob Casper: And I'll just
say I think that's true,
the point you raised for editors
of color, that you shouldn't be --
there wasn't -- there wasn't I
think [inaudible] editor previous.
You know, this sense [inaudible]
not promote this as, okay,
now you're an editor of color.
You must only publish
writers of color.
That's why you're here.
That's -- there are those
assumptions of all sides in terms
of how you have to
negotiate expectations
for cultural assumptions.
Don, you want to talk a
little bit about what it's
like to [inaudible] poetry
and the challenges of that?
>> Don Share: Yeah.
Well, I don't know.
I don't think about how I feel.
I often think about
how the world is.
I mean going back to what I
think we've all been saying
in not the same ways, but
related ways, if you look around
and your literature, your art, your
music isn't reflecting what you know
to be true, whatever you might --
whoever you might want to vote for,
there's something wrong
with your culture.
And so, I think a lot
of poets that I talk
to about these things actually
didn't set out to write
about terrible things
happening in the news.
But when they happen,
they are called upon.
And they will say something.
I think, you know, you know, there's
really no other way to respond
to it, other than to sort of measure
poetry against what we know to be,
you know, the feelings and
atmospheres that we all live
and breathe and eat
and walk around in.
I mean -- I mean everybody knows
things, but they don't want to --
you know, there are things that
are hard for people to admit.
There are things that are
hard for people to concede.
There are problems
that are hard to --
you know, and failures
that are hard to own up to.
And the poets aren't breaking
the [inaudible] so much.
If they have been called
upon to say things
that maybe haven't been said
before or hadn't been put in front
of an audience before, maybe
they have their own way of saying
about all these things together.
But there's a sort of startling
reality about conversations relating
to race that's interesting
to me because my grandparents
on one side -- great-grandparents
on the other were stateless people
who came here as immigrants
and didn't speak English,
and I'm the first person in my
family to be called a white person.
My brother couldn't get into an Ivy
League school because of the quotas.
My father couldn't be a
doctor for the same reason.
And I grew up in a bilingual
household, I mean the whole thing.
And my family now has black people,
white people, trans people in it.
I'm an American, about
as ordinary as can be.
And when I look around or even
when I hear what's going on,
it's astounding to me how
much in denial people are
because what is a white person?
Who are the people who are here,
and where did they come from?
How did they get here?
And what did their ancestors do?
So for me, you're just seeing
the shift that say 100,
125 years ago people assimilated
because it was a dream,
the American dream.
You know, now we know more about
this dream and what it means,
day to day, minute to minute
for people who can't access it.
So now we have to think
about our dreams differently.
And that's what we need to
count on the poets to do.
And they're doing it, you know?
So it's not just like
there's a group
and then there's another group.
I mean, you know, you run into this.
How do you, you know, want
to start classifying anybody,
whatever the terminology is?
It's very tricky because
in the end it can't be done
without dehumanizing people
or corralling sort of a group
of what are in the end
prejudices or stereotypes
or sort of group thinking.
And I think poetry has figured out.
Like, they have sorted
out a lot of this stuff.
And what we look around the
nation and the world and see is
that our politicians and people
out there haven't got it yet.
They haven't figured out how to
cope with different things yet.
They haven't been able to describe
what it's like to have conflict,
not only to be in conflict and
experience conflict, but to be made
up of conflictive kinds of
things in your background.
And I think again my belief in
poetry, which I've come by sort
of empirically not because I have
some ideology about it or, you know,
fantasy about it, but I think
the reality is, is you can --
these poets that we're
talking about are so good,
and the world is looking
to us for this.
What we need is for a lot
of people to sort of come
on board too and figure out how -
you know, what is a
national discussion
or international discussion of
conflict and pain and violence
and equality going to be like?
And the poets have got
-- are getting at it.
But the rest of the culture has
other things operating in it
that make it harder to value
the kind of work that we do.
But I do think that's changing
because I think it's hard
if you're an editor to really see
this, but like Poetry Magazine,
most of the people who
read it are not poets.
They're not other poets.
You often hear that poetry
is written for other poets.
Most of my readers
are general readers.
And they may hate or love
or whatever what they
see, but they get it.
They understand it.
And they're -- there is
resistance, and resistance is good
because it lays out for us the
work that needs to be done.
>> Cathy Park Hong: I
think it's [inaudible].
Like, it's not just a question of
diversity and having more poets.
I mean it's not just like, okay,
let's have more poems
that address race.
It's also kind of changing
our assumptions
about what a race poem is or what
a poet of color should write.
And I think that Noemi
Press is really doing it.
And I mean that's what we
were trying to do at jubilat.
jubilat is amazing how open
[inaudible] has been transformed.
But I do think that, you know,
poetry is still very
much an institution
where -- not Poetry Magazine --
>> Don Share: Right, right, right.
[ Laughter ]
>> Cathy Park Hong:
It's [inaudible].
>> Don Share: Yeah.
>> Cathy Park Hong: But I think
that it's also important, you know,
to be aware that I still
feel like a gatekeeper,
even though I'm someone of color.
I'm still -- I'm still a gatekeeper.
And that's something
that I acknowledge.
I do think that, you
know, we're thinking
about say prizes and so forth.
And there's still an
expectation on the kind
of race poem that's accepted
versus the kind of race poem
that either baffles you
or you're just like --
you don't understand it, or it's
a poem that has nothing to do
with race, but it's
written by a poet of color.
And I think a lot of the problem
is not just having more race poems
in there, but it's also
the fact that a lot
of times you have a
single frame of reference
for what a race poem should be.
And it's really important to
broaden that frame of reference.
You know, I think [inaudible]
an article where there was like,
you know, I think a lot of
marginalized groups get plagued
by this, where there's always
a simple story, you know,
which is like the single
immigrant story,
the single black story,
the single Asian story.
And everyone wants you to
kind of fit in that template.
And I see that happening a lot of
times, where the kind of attention
that the books get is that
they fit that template.
So it's really important.
So it's not just a -- I think
it's just also just, you know,
broaden not just the
voices, not this --
the kind of [inaudible] diversity,
but also changing the way we think
about what our assumptions as well.
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith: I
would add too that I think
that this historical moment has been
anticipated for many years in terms
of how we navigate rhetoric.
And we've become -- as a culture,
we've become so dichotomized
and so convinced of
our own infallibility.
But poetry demands that
we engage with nuance
and we engage with paradox.
And I think that's just
another really interesting way
in which poetry is
poised to be a place
where these conversations
are inevitable
because we're not writing.
We're not writing a list of goals,
and we're not writing op ed
positions, which again, you know,
I remember Deborah Tannen many,
many -- that book -- I don't --
I don't remember what it's called.
"You Just" -- not "You
Just Don't Understand",
but I think it was called "The
Argument Culture" I think.
And she talked about the experience.
And I'll never forget this
because when I was reading it,
this was like 15 years ago.
I thought, well, this seems a
little alarmist, where she talked
about how she was invited
to a talk show, and what --
as a linguist, you know, as a
scholar, she expected it to be,
you know, a conversation.
But it ended up them saying, "We
want you to have this position,
and then we're going
to bring in this person
to have this opposite
reaction to your position."
And that's not -- that's
not a productive way
to approach the world, and it
ends up being a very dangerous way
to approach the world because most
of us don't live on these ends.
Most of us live in the middle.
And so, I think that's
part of the reason
that poetry is having
this moment right now,
is that there aren't too
many places in the world
where we can have engaged, complex
conversations about these subjects.
And so, my hope is
-- and I'm, you know,
hearing that your sense
of general audience.
My hope is that poetry
infects all discourses,
and we start having more robust and
complex conversations because I --
these dichotomies terrify me
because they leave most people out,
except people who are shouting
the loudest at either end.
And that silences a lot of people.
>> Rob Casper: I'm going
to open it up to questions.
Let me just bring the mic to you
so that we can make sure
[inaudible] question.
>> Female Speaker: Well, the
question that first comes
to my mind is that is
there any time in which any
of us express ourselves either
verbally or with physical movement
or anything else in which
race is not being expressed?
>> Evie Shockley: I
understand the sort
of the spirit behind your
question, and I think you're right
that because we live in a society
that's grounded in racial ideology,
was founded on it, could not exist
as we know it without the history
that it's based in, in race, racism.
At any point, we are all speaking
from a racialized position
and that it's going
to have an impact.
It's going to inform what
we saw or what we do.
And it's going to inform how people
hear us on the other side, right?
So I think I would point to what
Carmen was saying about a spectrum.
I mean there are times
when race is not the thing
that a person is trying to express,
even if they're expressing it
from a position that is located
on a racialized landscape.
Maybe the part of what we're
thinking about together then is how
to -- how to ensure that the way
that landscape gets represented
in the journals, in the poetry
that's published, how to make sure
that landscape is represented
in its fullest.
So I hope that gets
at your question.
>> Rob Casper: I will also
say too that to sort of follow
up on what Cathy was talking about,
I do feel like there are a lot
of poets of color writing poems
that aren't -- that aren't, quote,
unquote, race poems, that
there's a place for that
in the sort of poetry landscape.
And I think that has
much to do with the --
not only the writers
writing that work,
but the publishers
championing that work.
That's really important.
It sort of goes to that question
because if we assume that, you know,
an African American writer can
only write about one kind of way
of seeing true race, it's
a very [inaudible] sort
of [inaudible] thinking and poems
we've discussed kind of problematize
that in all sorts of wonderful
ways and all sorts of positions.
But they do operate from
an eye that can be kind
of an empathetic eye too
[inaudible] trained to.
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith: I
think that the other piece
of that question, which
I think is so important,
is that even when race
doesn't feel --
feels neutral, it's still activated
in any -- in any engagement,
in any conversation, in
any exchange we have.
And it's so pervasive.
It's so pervasive that
we have trained ourselves
to take it for granted.
And as a -- as a poet
and thinking about how --
when let's I -- I'm also a teacher.
I teach a person of color, and I get
a sense of a student saying, "Well,
I have no use for this
because this is not my race.
So thank you."
But the reality is that
the same factors that,
even though let's say this
student is saying I'm --
this is a book by a black poet,
and I understand and I sympathize
and I feel the pain and suffering,
that in fact this same exact system
that's oppressing the black writer
writing about their question is
also oppressing this white person.
They just aren't aware of it.
They're just not aware that this
is a very huge system designed
to occlude the class
discrepancies that are growing
in the United States and the
ways in which our participation
and horizontal oppression keep those
with really the most
money in control.
And so, I think that race
that we participate in,
race's role as a straw
man discussion,
when really it's economic and
equities that's keeping us --
that's keeping us in many of
these problematic positions.
And so, I think that reading
all texts and through the lens
of race is useful now,
regardless of who's writing them,
because race is this huge
edifice that's -- I don't know.
I think that it's -- I think it's --
I think we're looking
at the wrong thing,
even though race is really
relevant and important, and it's --
and it's sort of inexcusable
not to be thinking about it.
I also think that there are many
layers to how we navigate it.
And class is a much bigger,
much more potent one.
And we're working against
each other.
We're really fighting against each
other when there's a much larger,
more ominous and dangerous force
that's working to oppress us.
>> [Inaudible] I was
teaching [inaudible].
There's a quote from [inaudible]
and I wanted to [inaudible] response
about the evolution
of the race poem.
The quote is, "The
universal is a fantasy.
But we are captive,
still, to a sensibility
that champions the universal
while simultaneously defining the
universal, still, as white.
We are captive, still, to a
style of championing literature
that says work by writers
of color succeeds
when a white person can
nevertheless relate to it --
that it 'transcends' its category."
And thinking about the race is
[inaudible] we are changing appears
how it's viewed [inaudible].
The sensibility of leaders
is just not [inaudible].
>> Cathy Park Hong: Well,
I think the white reader's
sensibility will evolve.
It's just through his
culture, you know?
And this is something that
we as editors are doing
and what I'm trying to do and
what everyone else is doing.
And I think that before there
wasn't -- there was, as we all said,
just a lot -- a lot less poets of
color, you know, being published.
Now there are more.
And so, it becomes that.
I think in terms of the evolution
of the race poem, what I am starting
to see I think, you know,
part of the growing pains that's
happening now is that, you know,
with the taking also
of the US Census
and the American demographic
changing,
the white American is slowly
realizing that they are --
white is not the universal
category, racial category,
which is very obvious that it's not.
We're only now really
becoming aware of that.
And it's also the way the
race poem can also evolve,
is how a poem by a white
poet is acknowledged
as a race poem, you know?
And I am also interested
in that as well.
Like, for instance, a
lot of the criticism
about the way we teach
[inaudible], you know,
writer or even an American
writer or, you know,
black writers [inaudible].
What is this poem about?
What does this poem say
about this demographic
or this short story
rather than [inaudible]?
And it's -- of course, we
have to expand and look
at that poem [inaudible].
But I'm also interested
actually in turning the table.
I mean like, okay, here is
a poem by say, for instance,
Tori Graham [assumed spelling].
How is this a white poem?
What does this say sociologically
about white people, you know?
And I think that's also in certain
ways we're going to acknowledge
that whiteness is actually
a category rather
than the universal is to
also kind of look at --
is to also look at what -- which is
what I think [inaudible] is doing.
And her textbook is a book
on whiteness, you know?
So, yeah.
>> Don Share: Something
in the first part
of what you're quoting goes back
to what William Empson
said many decades ago,
which is that the purpose in a
way of imaginative literature is
to put people in touch with
people whose values are different
from ours.
In other words, this idea
of the universal is just really
dangerous along the lines
that you've all described so well.
But in terms of teaching,
it's important too
because I think we see this a lot,
this thing that poetry's
good for you.
It's -- we see every day hot
takes in the media about how
if you read you get
empathy and all this stuff.
But I think we sort of
know it's not really true,
or we wouldn't be living in
the world that we're living in.
But on the other hand, this fear
of difference, whatever it is
or constitutes or however it can be
described, is something that seems
to make people very touchy,
and they do terrible things.
But I think what poetry is
going to do in a way, again,
that's been described already
is put the different ways
of describing this out there so that
people start to have a handle on it,
how they imagine what it's like
to be somebody who's in this kind
of constellation of circumstances.
But they didn't know that before.
So you can see poetry doing that.
The audiences are change --
the audience for poetry is
changing, which is really great.
And I think more importantly our
way of teaching not just poetry
but many things has
to somehow change.
And our civic culture,
which has to educate people,
and our politics has to change too.
It's kind of a tall
order, but it can be done.
And I mean whether or not it
can be done, it has to be done.
>> Evie Shockley: Oh, just really
quickly, I think I'm agreeing
with something you were saying,
but I really wanted to bring
out the aspect of audience
because there's a way that parts
of this discussion have
unfolded with a sort
of de facto white audience
I think in mind.
And the audience for poetry
had always been as diverse
as the audience for writers
of poetry and as America.
And it's the prefaces of
Noemi, you know, publishers,
independent from within different
groups who've been the conduits
for writers of color to write
to audiences of color for many,
many years, decades, a century.
It's the kind of finding a way
to bring not just the writers
but also the audiences together
that I think opens up a lot.
And that's what I think
we're all involved.
>> Female Speaker: [Inaudible].
Do you as a publisher think and
explore about the difference
of the [inaudible] between
Latinos and Latin Americans?
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith: Absolutely.
And I mean we also
publish translation,
a lot of Spanish-speaking poetries.
And my -- and my culture, my
background is -- I can't escape it.
I can't sort of exist outside of it.
And so, it absolutely
informs my ethos
and my politics as
a -- as a publisher.
And -- but with that in
mind, I love the new.
I love the transgressive.
And again, I would say that I
feel like this new generation
of poets are writing
the most exciting stuff
about race and identity.
And so, while I like -- I do --
I guess it's complicated because
I'm -- right now, I'm editing --
I'm doing some translation of the --
of a countercultural movement in
Peru called Globaca, which was borne
of the '80s of the kind of
martial law that was instituted
by President Fujimori at the
time, and I just see so much --
I also just see so much
similarity between some of the kind
of political turmoil
that's taking place
in late 20th century
Latin America and then --
and then contemporary
American politics
that the increasing
disparity between classes
that the horizontal
oppression, the dissatisfaction
with politics and the government.
So, you know, I feel like
we're moving into this chapter
in which we're becoming more
like the rest of the Americas.
And as a -- as a Latina, as a
woman of South American descent,
that's really, really
interesting to me.
And I'm paying attention
to what I know
about South American
political and literary history.
I'm just paying attention to
see what things kind of crop
up that seem similar as well.
And it's kind of surprising.
You probably a similar
experience being a translator.
>> Don Share: Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean it's funny, isn't it?
It's like American culture
is finally sort of kicking
and screaming, being brought
into its world citizenship,
something to which our
history has sort of --
>> Carmen Gimenez Smith: Yes.
>> Don Share: You know?
Sort of stuck us there,
and what we do
with it is something you
read about in the news.
But it's almost like our -- you
know, our existence as a group
of people coming from all kinds of
different places at every moment.
It's the movements and migrations
of people in the world that are
at its peak in recorded history.
Never before have so many
people been forced to move all
over the place that in a
way now it's like we're --
even just that we're
able to have or need
to have this discussion shows
you that change is happening
and that it's a -- that
it's a healthy thing.
But there's a lot of -- you pointed
out specifically danger
in it and invidiousness.
And, you know, I think that that
is just the price you pay for kind
of awakening people with language.
>> Rob Casper: Well, and
thankfully, poetry is there
to help us navigate,
as you discussed.
Thanks to all four
of our poet editors,
and thanks to all of
you for coming out.
There are books in the back
by all of our presenters.
So please buy some books.
Get them signed.
Also, you should see a
survey form near you.
Please do fill it out.
We use these surveys to
determine how we do our programs
going forward.
So we'd love to get your input.
You can give it to me.
You can leave it on the table.
And we hope to see you Thursday
at 6:30 for Law of Literature
with Monica Youn here at the Library
or for events coming forward --
coming -- happening in
the future this season.
So thanks again for coming up.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.